while I think the way that you're
talking is quite blunt about it there is
some truth to what you're saying and
more broadly there's other areas where I
think that probably applies as well
right yeah just beyond the physical
stuff what like can you give us some
other examples of of what you're talking
about
things that you talk to people on the
show about
um like one thing is that men shouldn't
sleep with so many women
and they'll say like men are responsible
for all the you know but I really think
you found them
no I'm serious it's like well they'll be
like well if the men weren't sleeping
around but it's like okay what percent
of men can sleep around right one out of
three men are sexless so but by this
logic like it's more on the women than
the men but it's like then they put it
on the small percentage of men that are
sleeping around does that make sense
yeah yeah it does make sense I don't
know if you've heard that argument or
not I haven't actually no yeah I've
never heard anyone blame the men for the
fact that women are doing a lot of
sleeping around that's really I hear it
all the time yeah they always say like
um women
um like but the men are sleeping around
when we talk about like women being
[__] yeah yeah it's like but the man
but the men slept with her too but but
but
I also oh I think it's 100 the woman's
fall if you get pregnant yeah it's
interesting why 100
um because we have 41 forms of birth
control
and
um the what if birth control fails
condoms what if you someone could I know
someone who was using condoms and birth
control
[Music]
okay yeah but you're saying adoption I
mean I don't believe in abortion but
it's legal so then you you have 100
control over who's born as a woman
um
there's always a risk of pregnancy you
know so it's it is is that really fair
to say that yes
but I guess because the man only has one
choice oh I guess you could do two
vasectomies condom no condom yeah right
where the woman has like 20 choices
abortion no abortion plan b or no plan B
41 forms of birth control or No 41 forms
of birth control
um what else is there adoption no
adoption
um child support no child support
letting him have access to his kids not
letting him have access to his kids the
women have all the choice so it's like
if we have all the choice why don't we
have all the responsibility
because there's two people involved in
the creation of a child right but
there's six choices for the woman and
one for the man and the other thing like
the woman can lie where the man can't
the woman can say she's on birth control
say she took the plan B say she has an
IUD and the man could be sleeping with
someone and not even know that where the
woman knows if he's wearing a condom or
not wearing a condom so there's only one
situation like the woman is the only one
that's in a situation where she can
fully consent to everything assuming
there's no grape whatever because she
knows all the details where the man does
it yeah I mean also there's there's
several instances and of a man removing
a condoms during sex a woman noticing
and a man ejaculating in a woman
I don't believe that
I feel like that's like a cop-out to be
honest okay I feel like the girls just
say that I don't really believe it you
didn't notice okay
so what I'm curious about is what
happens when you say all this to a bunch
of random people that you've brought in
off the street
they're like super understanding
[Laughter]
yeah I don't see that yeah I don't see
that yes Americans don't get it I got it
I got I got whale attacked for one of
these opinions because this girl I was
doing Street interviews and this girl
was like
I can't walk home alone in life night my
life is so hard and I was just like she
was she was a whale you know what I mean
she was overweight very fat yeah yeah
and so what she did was she was like
um and I was like well why don't you
just not live in a big city why don't
you just live somewhere safer why don't
you just not walk home alone at night in
a big city
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime and then she's like well
and then she attacks me she she tries to
she's like I'll have you you slack I
didn't know what a slag meant okay I
didn't even know what a slag was but she
was like I'll have you you slack I'll
have you and I was like have me like
what
and so then then she like knocks the mic
out of her hand my friend had to like
pull her away
and then I got it taken off of my
YouTube for privacy [__] you attacked
me and she wouldn't leave my yeah sorry
so yeah they're really understanding
yeah that's so I I'm kind of lost for
words a little bit because uh yeah she
was like super nice I love Britain yeah
yeah yeah you see you see some of those
girls uh up and down High Street so on a
Saturday night yeah I mean some it just
depends on the girl like some girls
other girls say they've changed their
entire opinion I've had some girls
um say they never thought of it that way
have you always had these opinions or
has your view of this evolved over time
I've always been more conservative
um some things
I recently decided that women shouldn't
vote
decided women shouldn't vote yeah that's
a new opinion why is that okay I'll take
one for the team yeah okay why shouldn't
women vote because
um we're chemically different every
single day right yeah and I just and
like okay we make seven hold on does
that mean you shouldn't be on YouTube
then because you're chemically different
your opinions could be [__] because
it could be yeah
should I be banned off of YouTube
doesn't have to do with voting it's like
a false equivalency okay so to me it's
like okay I feel like if [__] goes south
who's going to war
okay
let me yeah let me let me start from the
beginning let me start actually I wanna
I wanna start from power I don't want to
be jumping on this [__] train I want
to start with how I got this opinion
okay I want to start let me let me okay
because I I heard from a guy named Rollo
tomasi genius right very very smart he's
a pickup artist isn't he no no do you
know no no no no no no I don't know
anything about it what is it so um no he
he a lot of the stuff in the space of
YouTube I meant like he's just like one
of the thought leaders I would say Okay
um but he's not a pickup artist no no
okay is he the Italian comedian who's in
his 70s and talks about no no it's not
no he's not no no okay sorry go ahead we
keep interrupting it
close a little bit yeah and when
I thought it was crazy okay okay but
what I heard was that women didn't want
to vote
so when I was like what do you mean
women didn't want to vote like the first
one they threw themselves under [__]
carriages some dead yeah right but was
that women at large no no it wasn't the
majority of women back then we always
talk about the suffragettes but there's
also the anti-suffragettes yeah and that
was the majority of women when asked if
they wanted to vote said no in the U.S I
don't know what it was like here okay
you know this is us and I was like why
did women not want to vote
now so I read some of their their
writings from back then okay and they
basically said this is the beginning of
the breakdown of the family because back
then when you got married you became one
and you trusted your husband to make
that decision okay now that was one
argument and I was like okay well but
Society is a little different today
argument number two back then they had
to be drafted
so any woman
that wanted to vote
had to go to war because you're voting
in the U.S anyway for your
commander-in-chief because
if they go to war who's going to have to
deal with the consequence and that's
where we're at is because
if [__] goes south and we go to war the
men are the one that are going to have
to deal with the consequences so yeah I
felt like if we want to vote we should
be equally because women want equality
equally drafted just like the men
and now you're thinking we don't have
the draft anymore right that's probably
your thought however however we have
selective service in the U.S meaning
that if a man if there's a crisis right
and we do go to war the men have to be
like like they they then can be taken to
I'm butchering it a little bit does that
make sense but
and if they don't do this they're fined
a hundred thousand dollars
is that equal is that fair
where we have the same rights but we
don't have the same responsibilities if
[__] goes south I don't think that's
fair so I thought about it would I want
to be in selective service if I had to
pick
my answer is no no I will give up the
right to vote to not have to do that and
I think that would be fair I think
feminists they want equality
but they don't want the responsibility
that comes with it that's my opinion
okay
now what's interesting about that is in
some countries like Israel it's men and
women through national service yeah I
don't want that so you keep me out of
that keep me
but also women are far more likely to
vote for peaceful and left-leaning party
women are more likely to rage War fun
fact the last 500 years between um night
in the last 500 years
queens were more likely to wage war than
Kings also dispute the idea that
left-wing parties are more peaceful but
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible